hey everyone
welcome to analytics in a multi-cloud
world
i'm emily rapp product manager in
bigquery
we are facing a data explosion
175 zettabytes that's
21 zeros 21 zeros
of data in the world by 2025. where is
it coming from
we have cat videos server logs
monitoring
there's retail data when you're thinking
about e-commerce
it's a lot more than just that final
transaction it's every point
on the sales cycle iot
manufacturing even my washing machine is
connected to the internet
and therefore generating data
we have all of this data at our
fingertips
but we just can't quite get to it
because we're living in this world of
data silos
there's organizational separation i.t
departments are often centralized and
they are separate from
the central data department if there is
one which are even then further
separated into the business units
and those business units also have
analysts data scientists
working and trying to understand
problems
it's fragmented you have data
originating from a bunch of different
sources
it's all in different formats with
various levels of processing
this means that our analysts our data
scientists are users
our users are using too many tools
have to get data from too many places
and they're making too many copies
why is this happening a key component
is shown in one of the gartner cloud
adoption surveys
81 of companies who are using public
clouds
are actually using more than one cloud
provider
and so that means that multi-cloud
management is becoming
actually it is a true challenge
i.t leaders they want to be agile
flexible
secure and analysts and data scientists
the ones that are actually doing the
day-to-day work with that data
they're just trying to help their
organization make the right decisions
and even if organizations decide to have
a centralized data approach
like we talked about in the earlier
slide there's still always going to be
separate business units
subsidiaries partners multi-cloud is
and will be the world we're working in
we need to solve for these macro
challenges so today
we're introducing bigquery omni a
flexible multi-cloud solution
that lets you analyze data across clouds
you don't have to leave bigquery it's
your familiar interface
same experience but now
you can actually reach out reach out
across those silos
bigquery omni is now an alpha and what's
really cool is that it's powered by
anthos
we don't have to do that moving and
copying of data as a data analyst
in the marketing department bigquery
omni enables me to use historical sales
data
in my upcoming marketing campaigns using
our orders data
we're going to validate the hypothesis
that we should be focusing our marketing
efforts beyond just food and beverage
our first query uses the hyperloglog
approximation function
to sort the departments by number of
orders
we are using our read-only external
connection retail read
to get the data from the order's
external table
the query returns the department sorted
by number of orders
and as we can see all top 10 are either
food or beverage
this validates our hypothesis that we
should be focusing
our marketing efforts on this customer
segment household or personal care
product purchasers now we need to build
a list of ids using our customer data
set
the customer data has personal
information including name
and zip code and we need that data to
stay within the aws region
however we do have a de-identified user
id field that we can use in our
campaigns
our next query will build our audience
segment buyers of household
are personal care products since our
campaigns are regionalized we only want
customers from oregon
or washington now we have a list of ids
that can be used in any marketing
activation channel
we want this data to be accessible to
our marketers not just the analysts
so i use our right connection to export
the query result
to the marketing folder that they have
access to
and that is how you can use bigquery
omni for data-driven marketing
activation
that was pretty cool wasn't it so let's
talk about
bringing multi-cloud analytics to your
data
first we have to break down those silos
get you to getting insights faster
tap into the power of bigquery it's cost
efficient
no moving or copying you just instantly
query
instantly get your results with that
consistent experience
it doesn't matter if your data is in
google cloud
aws or coming soon azure
you can just use the same standard sql
the same bigquery familiar interface
write queries build dashboards because
the reality
is data it's not just numbers
it's not just bytes stored in some data
center somewhere
it's the way that we can actually
communicate we can tell stories
we can answer questions we want you to
be able to have the ability to actually
work across those data silos that data
that was at your fingertips
let's get closer to it and we're able to
do that
because under the hood we use anthis
if we think about bigquery bigquery is
the separation of
storage and compute what does that mean
it means you can scale up
and say hey sometimes when things are
going crazy you may need a little bit
more compute
in other cases maybe now you're
gathering a bunch of data and so you
need storage
we were thinking about how do we solve
this data silo question
but the challenge was we have to figure
out how to get compute
to the data even if that data is in
another cloud
so bigquery omni we run the compute
clusters in this dremel
on anthoclusters in aws
we have a secure connection because it's
really critical we think of that single
pane
that the control plane and the metadata
can remain
on google cloud but only the query
result
actually passes through the bigquery
routers and then our secure connection
to the next region aws or azure
that connection can also be used when
users choose to bring the results back
but the key piece is it's choice for you
you can bring them back or you can do
everything within aws
bigquery omni is a fully managed service
a question i hear
is oh so i have to you know use my
anthos or my compute
nope we got that covered we do need your
storage
and it's really critical that you
maintain the access control to that
storage
but with the compute resources running
locally
all of that's done behind the scenes and
you can just
answer those questions
so how do we actually solve some of
those business
scenarios with bigquery omni
this one's funny this is my old world up
until recently
september when i joined bigquery i was
the
infamous marketing analytics ads
measurement
specifically how many people saw my ad
it's a surprising hard question and
actually it's even harder
to actually think about okay now i
figured out
what's going on in my marketing
campaigns what about my audience
behavior
in my apps on my site what impact do
those two have on my sales
so let's think about how could we solve
that problem how can we see the impact
we could visualize so use bigquery
query google analytics 360 ads data in
google cloud
and then tap into your e-commerce data
and app data that's on aws s3 now with
looker
you can build a dashboard so you or
those executives that you know we all
have to worry about
can actually look at what the audience
behavior is and purchases
alongside spend it's pretty amazing
what seeing something visually can do
it's like oh wait there's a spike
and then you also talk to people it's
like no really building a dashboard when
data comes
from all those different places and more
importantly
making sure that if you share that
dashboard with someone they're not going
to see something that they shouldn't
it's surprisingly challenging
now let's get a little bit deeper this
is something i'm sure probably uh many
of you are familiar with
the okay my uh business team
said you need to use the app data that
we have to do smart things and we need
that data
and we need that data here and it needs
to be formatted
and easy to get to and fast so as a data
engineer
you end up running thousands of daily
jobs to process logs
and build cross-cloud etl pipelines and
what happens if those pipelines go
down so i've actually seen it where
instead of fixing the pipeline companies
will sometimes just hire consultants to
respond to tickets to answer questions
it's that complicated
bigquery omni it's not always
just about the like getting new things
with dashboards
it's looking at your existing workloads
and how you can optimize them
you have those petabytes of click stream
logs that we talked about
and for some reason every app always
ends up going into different
s3 buckets with rk files
today you have those thousands of jobs
that we talked about running
and all you're trying to do is build
audience lists in csv files of your
active users
replace that with a single sql query
that any analyst can run
so now that any analyst or data
scientist can just run a sql query
let's think about how that data
scientist can actually
use the data from sales to not just
understand their existing audience
but reach new audiences more effectively
let's get started with bigquery omni
in the bigquery ui on google cloud
choose the public cloud region where
your data is located
and run your query the same query you
would use to work with data that's
stored on gcp
the query is passed to the other public
cloud and all of the compute
is done within that public cloud region
the results are returned to the bigquery
ui
or you can choose to export the results
directly back to your data storage
on that public cloud which means there's
no cross-cloud movement of results or
data
you can start using bigquery omni right
away
there's no need to do any formatting or
transformation of your data
bigquery omni supports formats such as
avro csv
json orc and parquet you also don't need
to move or copy your raw data
out of the other public cloud do any
cluster management or provision any
resources
all computation occurs within bigquery's
multi-tenant service
which is running on the region where the
data is currently located
behind the scenes bigquery's query
engine is running on our anthos clusters
within the bigquery managed service
we get the data from data storage within
your account only once you've authorized
permissions
via your other public cloud's iam roles
those roles are tied to a bigquery omni
connection object
you can change grant or revoke access at
any time
and the connection object can be shared
to multiple users within that same
project
we maintain a secure connection to bring
your query results
back to google cloud welcome
to bigquery omni okay so
we did that query we exported it
back to aws and now it's time to
activate your cross cloud data story
which means think about that google
analytics data that's coming in
think about the s3 data storage and take
those audience lists
and do things like look-alike targeting
ever had that experience where you buy
something
and you still see the ad over and over
and over again
and you're like come on i bought that
thing already stop
wasting your ads on me now we can
actually solve that
because we can tie that commerce data to
the ad platform
in a safe and secure way
so let's recap embrace a flexible
multi-cloud analytic solution with
bigquery omni
we're going to break down silos get
straight to the
getting insights part of data analytics
it's the fun part anyways
having a consistent experience across
clouds
it doesn't matter where your data sets
are you should be able to use the
standard sql
bigquery interface write your queries
build your dashboards
it's all about taking that consistency
and familiarity
to accelerate the time to insights you
want to be able to
wake up in the morning check your phone
be like okay we're good
and go back to sleep not have to worry
about writing a whole ton of different
queries in different tools before you
know the state of your business
and all this is possible because of
anthos
dremel was built by google dremel is
what powers bigquery
anthos it's that next stage thinking
about that gartner quote
81 of companies it's probably actually
more than that i would say maybe think
about
everyone has some part of their business
that's on some other cloud
and so by bringing the data to you we
bring the compute to where your data is
we worry about the infrastructure don't
worry about spinning up clusters
managing them
we got that you focus on driving the
business
doing some really cool data science
making the decisions you need with data
not worrying about how do i set this up
and what pipeline should i run and oh
wait
they broke now i have to hire a whole
bunch of
people to just answer tickets
let's get started get started with
bigquery on me
let's take it to the next level take
your multi-cloud analytics strategy that
you've built from a platform and it
perspective
and bring it to your data bigquery omni
is an alpha
so if you're interested please go to the
link
and fill out the form let's break down
some silos